hi everyone my name is Sam
I am very honored also just very excited
to be kicking off I believe the first
talk on this semester quarter new year
and I guess new decade I was sort of
brainstorming different topics to talk
about through the holidays and I
remember I was actually in Bali with a
group of friends and I was on a call
that's where I took this shot I was on a
call with Tom and and Luke I believe and
the advice that Tom gave me on what to
talk about was to imagine myself now
many moons ago when I was a student and
what sort of wisdom would I want to
impart now that I've had whatever
experiences I've had on myself back then
if I were like my only audience and the
first thought I had was that I'm
certainly in no position of authority to
offer sort of any wisdom on on this
topic to anyone but I have had a set of
experiences that I feel like are
interesting enough to share about and
especially as we're coming into 2020 and
I think Tech is getting an increasingly
bad rap sometimes with like regards to
its influence on society and I think
it's already well sort of widely
understood that startups are difficult
in their own right to do they can be
really stressful they can be just
requiring a lot of effort the the
thought was to go through my personal
experiences and think through like what
makes it worth it to go through the
process and how you like get through the
mentality of doing startups in this sort
of my way which is highlighted on the
sort of title that everything is worse
than you think
and I figured a great place to start is
just sort of
a run-through of my own life in sort of
highly curated Instagram story fashion
through my experiences this past holiday
in Bali so here we go
okay cool so I think that's pretty cool
it seems like I might be you know
hashtag living my best life but the the
reality of this whole trip actually was
that I I was I was quite miserable and
and you know in this time an agent it's
not surprising that like what you see on
Instagram stories isn't represented
necessarily of reality and and maybe
we're just filling out a bunch of fake
news everywhere but like the the the
truth of what I was experiencing through
this trip was very early on I end up
with food poisoning and then right after
that I when I was chasing waterfalls as
you saw I got a cut when I slipped on
some rocks and then I got infected and I
don't know if it was related to that but
like right afterwards I got like
severely ill with either some flu or
virus or disease and he just put me out
the rest of the trip and so it turns out
my my most memorable sort of experience
through this whole trip was was none of
these clips and this is seared in my
mind actually this experience it was
actually when early on I was on a car
ride trip which was about two hours back
to the villa where the the group of us
were staying and I remember I was
already not feeling well at the
beginning of this trip so all day I'd
been drinking mainly like these these
tropical jungle juices and in tonics and
then about ten minutes into this journey
I just I just threw up everything in my
stomach right in front of me in the car
and I like I so distinctly remember in
between the heaves I was just crying and
I had my friend beside me and the driver
and we just we had to all get back to
this destination still two hours away
cuz that's where we all were and I just
remember sitting there in the pool my
own vomit questioning my life decisions
and just realizing that we still had to
go the rest
the way through this two hours and that
that was how I kicked off my trip to
Bali and I just remember through the
rest of my journey I was just just as I
mentioned before miserable I there's a
lot of mosquitos in Bali that that's
fine you know it's like nature when I
got in the infection I wasn't sure
whether it was because after I got cut
in the waterfall there was like a local
lady who cut my band-aid with this
personal scythe that she just happened
to have at hand or whether it was like
the the dirty waterfall water but I
never figured that out it didn't really
matter to top it all off I got to just
sort of freak out over this rat I
discovered in my room that here I just
wanted to show this he's coming he's
coming for me no he's running back but
he can't escape how did he get in here
I've cornered him and he knows it Oh God
okay so I'm just deliriously talking to
myself really obviously not in control
of the situation and why am i sharing
all this so the the point of all these
experiences is it turns out that's sort
of what stops are like it's like sitting
in a pool of your own vomit as you're
like dying of an infection and then
being trapped in a room of like insects
and rats so that's why the the way I
wanted to sort of start off this talk
was just giving you a quick sense of my
perspective of things and then maybe
where I can actually begin is just sort
of whirlwind tour of my own background
yeah I was born in Iowa City my parents
were immigrants from Hong Kong and so
that's me and my sister I was born there
but actually grew up in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania I remember actually much of
my childhood was centered around I did a
lot of studies in PN
no carnegie-mellon and actually my
college essay was about how as a child I
was really curious and stuck my hand in
door hinge my mom just slammed it so I
actually she chopped off the tip of my
middle finger and like you know there's
a set of images where I was just in like
a full hand cast as a child but then my
my essay was about how I you know
persevered through that ended up
studying a lot of piano and then before
I graduated high school actually
performed at Carnegie Hall over in New
York and that was really exciting to me
except what I realized afterwards is
that in order to have a career in
something that you're passionate about
in the arts you have to be the best at
it at least this was you know in my mind
at the time or otherwise there there
weren't really too many paths to success
there and so instead I decided that the
much more rational approach was to study
computer science join startups and then
end up building a company where then
other artists and creators could then
find a means to build out a career
around their passion in their craft but
I'm jumping a little bit ahead I want to
go back on campus I actually the thing I
remember having a lot of fun with was
actually delivered in and out burgers
and so this was before door - and all
the stuff I don't know what you folks
use nowadays but this is an article from
2006 in the Stanford daily which which
sort of dates me but basically talking
about how I created a website people on
campus were ordering in and out burgers
and then I would come through in my
Honda and just hand-deliver burgers so
it you know a lot hustle by after I
graduated I worked at two startups that
you probably haven't heard of one was
called name the other called loped you
may have heard of the the people that
started these companies Marc Andreessen
started Ning he now runs of course the
VC firm injuries and Horowitz and he was
also fond of Netscape and then looped at
the time Sam Altman had dropped out of
Stanford he later went on to
by Common Era now is currently running
open AI and so as a quick aside one of
the things I certainly found out about
Silicon Valley is that the network is is
quite small and you end up running into
the the same people over and over again
in the industry and because of that it's
really important to sort of foster great
relationships I mean a cuz it's just a
good human thing to do but then also
because you never really know like where
everyone's gonna go in their career and
what there's gonna develop going back to
the case of mark and Sam mark ended up
writing my recommendation for the code
term program over at Stanford so that
was really helpful and then Sam Sam has
been really instrumental in my career
both as an investor and companies I've
done but then also in helping me out get
a role in Y Combinator when he was
running it so I think it's just really
important to to care deeply about the
community around you and the people that
both you can help support and then they
can help support you okay
then I started a company you definitely
haven't heard about called ad world I'm
still recovering from the Bali stuff and
that was acquired by a company called
AdMob and then they in turn were
acquired by Google so I went through
that whole process came back afterwards
to here at Stanford and the startx great
program run by great people actually and
still being run now where I was an
entrepreneur residents worked on a few
companies here and then reconnected with
my as we noted earlier my freshman year
roommate Jack started the company
patreon patreon I imagine there are
folks not familiar with us is actually
quite a cool company
this is Amanda Palmer she's a sort of
kick-ass musician we help sort of
creatives artists get direct funding and
financing from their community and so
these artists can ultimately build a
career focus on what they're passionate
about and in return the community gets
access to the artists they get to
develop a connection with a sense of
intimacy or they get access to exclusive
behind-the-scenes
and learn more about the artist okay I
want to get back to the original topic
so the way I think about talks is
primarily through stories and so I I
went through my whole past experiences
and I realized that like the struggles
and hardships I went through sort of
centered around these three themes and
and that's really what I'm gonna talk
about today and either they were
personal experience or something I
witnessed and so the structure is I'm
gonna talk about the three themes of
hardships that you know I've gone
through and then sort of on a broader
level talk about some thoughts on maybe
how you can approach and deal with them
when you go through these yourself okay
so nobody cares about your problem this
actually I think is surprising to most
people like in some sense I think people
expect that they have to sell there's a
lot of common knowledge out there around
how you want to find your first users
being really passionate about your
problem
but it turns out even if at least this
is what I have experienced across a few
startups even if you have strong
conviction the early users always seem
to they always seem to - at the point of
closing not maybe initial discussions
not come on board and I found this out
sort of over and over again the example
with Admiral initially was that we had
what we believed was a really compelling
solution to a problem about mobile ads
at that time where you couldn't change
out two different mobile ad networks
without submitting a whole new app into
the App Store and so for us we realized
that we were making we were using this
in our own apps and we were making
thousands more dollars in advertising
revenue and we figured other companies
with making tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands more and it just
seemed like a no-brainer and so we
actually went through the entire like
app store rankings list contacted all
the developers and we didn't get a
single replied
and email and it just looked like
despite it being obvious that you would
make more money nobody really cared same
thing happened with patreon surprisingly
- so Jack had a great network of artists
and creators that he knew and then we
collectively put together a list of
maybe like a hundred folks that we felt
could really benefit from sort of
launching with us and and that we would
line up some press and they could sort
of ride that as they were launching out
with their audience and so we went
through that list contacted all these
different youtubers creators and also
nobody launched with us and so I
remember like one of the emails that
that Jack ended up showing me was from
one of sort of the aggregators who was
like also pitching this idea to two
folks and you know the the language that
this person used was can't say that the
interest level is sky-high we'll keep
pushing and and enough nothing came out
of it and so when we launched patreon it
was just Jack his roommate at the time
and then his now-wife
Natalie and that's all we had that was
the only people that were willing to
give us a shot on this and obviously I
think things worked out but and I'll
address some of that later but I think
it's very common that until you can
actually show an example of success and
thrive those initial users people aren't
very interested in the case of Admiral
it wasn't until we started sort of
publishing some of our own numbers about
how much money we were making on to
external news sources that people found
that we had some legitimacy okay I find
this to be an interesting problem - that
your plan just ends up being wrong all
the time and the the example I use from
patreon is that we were really sure that
the the way that would make us unique as
a platform is that we would
allow artists because we believe that
new influencers nowadays weren't sort of
locked into this album release cycle and
so they would release content whenever
it made sense for them so we were
convinced and had really strong
conviction that what needed to exist on
this platform is the ability to only
charge when you've released a new song a
new album a new piece of art and so that
was the the crux of like our value
proposition with patreon and it turns
out like you know after we launched even
though that's how we launched artists
cared much more about a stable revenue
stream where they would have consistent
money come in every month and so they
could actually think about planning for
their finances and a career which makes
a lot of sense but this sort of
situation I find yeah eventually we had
like 95% of artists just doing sort of a
monthly payment plan instead of per song
or per work and and I found and just
talking to a lot of different folks that
this seems to always happen to so I was
back in I don't know what this was 2010
I guess working at this incubator called
Dogpatch labs and this was the same
incubator where across the table both
chemists Isham who I think is gonna be
doing the last talk in this series was
working and building out Instagram but
actually at the time still using all the
Bourbon branding and stuff because that
was the first company that they had been
working on and so I remember I was like
curious about all the other groups
working working around me so I got set
up on Instagram with Mike
Kevin's co-founder and then I asked
Kevin like what what what do you I'm
curious you know what what's your plan
what are you thinking about with with
this company and at the time and this
was I think as they were pivoting out of
bourbon what he described was a
Instagram was just going to be easier to
use than all the other photo services
but their their strategy was that it
would be the first
as part of a lifestyle suite of apps
that could encompass different things
and so you know this one was about
sharing images your life they could have
a location oriented one down the road
and it turns out that Instagram was
compelling enough where none of that
other planning had to materialize at all
for them and then they went on from
there same thing happened with a little
similar thing where early on I was I had
met Ben Silverman who was the founder of
Pinterest and we were doing a few
strategy sessions because this is before
he had launched Pinterest on just things
that we were building we were both
trying to come up with startup things at
that time and the the original demo that
he showed me that prior to to Pinterest
was actually a mobile app that allowed
you to sort of group different fashion
together and then eventually like
purchase different clothes and things
like that and so then Ben is an amazing
strategic thinker based based on the
experience of my conversations with him
in the past but the point of all this is
like I think you just get going you if
you allow every single time that you're
proven wrong on the planning that you
have laid out you're almost guaranteed
to run into this and so if you can
develop the mentality that it's not a
big deal and that you have conviction on
some core principle of what you're
working on it's okay for your plan to be
absolutely wrong
it also helps in these cases that I
think the folks found success afterwards
but even in the case where you have to
pivot or do something different I think
just being comfortable the fact that
more likely than not you can't
anticipate like the mentality of groups
of people is is is what everyone ends up
facing regardless of how successful they
are down the road okay
this one is is more personal to me and I
think it has a lot to do and maybe folks
here share this mentality with both like
a desire to optimize the things that you
do with your life and then also this
idea that you want to be questioning all
the time if you're making the right
choices and have the things that you've
done been working out and so for me
particularly about everything that I
faced with continuously I find myself
oftentimes in this maybe like toxic
cycle of thinking through the choices
that should have been in in the worst
case getting to regret about it and so
just highlighting a few examples of this
in my own life early on in AdWords that
was the first company I founded life we
got an offer from this company named
Quatro Wireless and so both me and my
co-founder really young at the time we
didn't know what to make of all this and
I remember when we asked our investors
for sort of advice they gave us some
opinion that basically led us to going
okay
we're not gonna do this acquisition and
then afterwards we saw quickly that
Apple acquired Quattro and then Apple
appreciated itself and the deal ended up
valuing us around 150 million but we
never we never took that and that was
that was at that time us myself being
like 25 years old something that I
really was fixated on for a really long
time as in like how could I have made a
better decision here or how could I have
had a better thought process around this
and then it sort of happened again I
don't know if you folks have heard of
this company named fab but on the next
company when I was working at Starbucks
then I started this is sort of silly but
this fab was also interested in
acquiring us and so I remember reaching
out to a few folks and asking for advice
here again and especially in the context
of what happened before thinking that
maybe
wanted to go through this sort of
acquisition but then ultimately decided
not to and then shortly afterwards we
sort of couldn't escape the news where
it just seemed like fab was was taking
off
and and the reason they were interested
in us is because we had to help them set
up with group buying through our
platform at that time but yeah like our
my co-founders and I were just sort of
sitting there not freaking out but just
thinking that we were bad at making
choices and and ultimately I also
remember like seeing all these articles
because this happened very shortly after
we stopped working on that original
platform and then I'd reconnected with
Jack and we had launched patreon at this
time and looking at also whether it made
sense to to go back and possibly talk to
fab early on because we weren't getting
a lot of traction in terms of people
being interested in in patreon at the
beginning and it it was doubly true
because the day that Jack came to me and
this I had that date marked because the
day that Jack came to me I was also
working on another idea for like
freelance photography and and the
TechCrunch article for that just come
out so when I originally had met Jack we
met at this place called coffee bar in
San Francisco I thought we were just
gonna talk about an idea that he had so
that could give him some advice and I
remember he he came to me at conv he's
like okay Sam I don't know what the
process is for this do we I have to get
a couple of like non-disclosures and can
we can we sign a few documents so that
you don't steal my idea and I remember
telling Jack look ideas don't matter at
all like you can tell me you could not
doesn't doesn't really matter to me I'm
happy to offer my thoughts if you want
to share about what you're doing but
otherwise you know it's great to catch
up it's very cool seeing you on YouTube
these days and he he end up sharing me
the idea around
and how he thought all his artists and
friends had huge influence but weren't
making money at all on YouTube and then
the immediate next thing I told him was
Jack don't tell anyone else this idea
I'm gonna start working on this now and
I began coding that night and I was just
both of us were just convinced that
there was something here and it was a
personal sort of problem both for Jack
obviously as an artist and creator but
then also for myself just having gone
through my own experiences and
fortunately for us fab totally just fell
in sync so I didn't regret it later on
okay so how how do you think about
approaching these problems when you're
you're dealing with them and you know I
I have this mentality that I'm sort of
gonna indulge myself here but Jack made
a video my co-founder about patreon a
few years ago and it's a little bit it's
a little bit gross but it also I think
is like highlights the point that I'm
trying to make with a thing and you just
keep grinding on it and you work so hard
and you don't sleep and you just kill
yourself to turn a vision into a reality
and Sam is my co-founder this video
isn't supposed to be about him but every
time I think about that first year of
patreon it becomes about Sam because Sam
would code in bed and he would like fall
asleep for an hour and then he'd wake up
and he'd keep coding and they'd policy
but he wake up and he keep going he was
the only engineer and we were servicing
you know thousands and thousands of
accounts and only Sam in his room
disgusting because he just he was around
the clock working so hard look at this
has on his desk it's
unbelievable
he would I mean he hates when I show
these photos but I just have to because
it's this this is the these photos are
the embodiment of what it means to take
a thing in your head and make it real
and put it in the world
it's creation it's the making of a thing
it's a turning of us something into a
reality I'm so grateful to Sam he has a
work ethic unlike anyone else I know
this is my favorite photo of Sam this is
how I remember Sam the first makes
honestly I get emotional looking at this
photo I'm thinking about this it he gave
himself fully to patreon to to our
mission to what we're doing and
okay so before I totally turn on the
waterworks on camera here okay so the
the thing obviously aside from finding
uh you know it helps to find a
co-founder where you both love each
other dearly is I want to justify what's
actually going on here so it looks like
a carnival I kidding eggs on my desk
because there's obviously no place to
cook them so I think I was using it sort
of poorly as like the overfill of trash
and it didn't just but the the point
more here that I'm trying to make is to
find the thing that you can be obsessive
about to the point and and this is this
is obviously the wrong like it is
unhealthy but like to the point where
the other things get phased out in your
mind and they don't matter right and so
when you're dealing with things like
regretting other decisions that you made
or that your plan isn't working out or
that just nobody cares about what you're
doing if you yourself are convicted and
you feel that you care deeply about your
problem and it's the only thing you can
focus on then also your personal hygiene
but but beyond that like you can get
through most of the issues which doesn't
guarantee success but at least you know
that you're working on something that
you that you feel is worthy of your time
and so I I find that that this notion of
like phasing everything out and just
being like laser focus on the thing that
you care about is is actually quite sort
of almost ubiquitous like there's this
language is used very consistently among
other successful companies so like
Patrick Collison of stripe has this
tweet where he describes creating strike
required obsessive intensity and then he
notes that may be better founders could
have worked you know smarter instead of
harder but but at least for stripe they
just had to work that hard
and I like Paul Graham who started Y
Combinator's response to this to that
effectively the the implication is that
in every case startups just require and
an immense amount of intensity he
describes it as the way Patrick what he
means that by better founders is that
it's an empty set of folks and that just
everyone is gonna need to work that hard
and I actually found the the best
example or at least the example that
resonated the most with me here came up
during a discussion with a friend of
mine on this Bali trip too and it had to
do with this friend of mine worked at a
hedge fund called Bridgewater associates
and it's it's the number one largest
hedge fund in the world but it's also
really famous for the founder Ray Dalio
who has this book called principles just
instilling this uniquely intense culture
which most likely isn't for every
company but a few tenants of that
culture are primarily around this notion
of extreme transparency and candidness
in feedback to improve everyone within
the organization and so meetings where
you have like three people who discuss a
topic are recorded broadcast out to the
rest of the organization and then in
real time people provide feedback and
criticize you on points that you make
and so you you get to see this sort of
matrix of feedback continuously on your
performance at at all times within this
organization and so the founder Ray
Dalio is he condensed a lot of these
principles and then wrote out this book
which became like a number one New York
Times bestseller a few years ago but the
the story that my friend shared when he
was working at Bridgewater associates
came from from recently where he was
noting that Ray Dalio was
in a meeting room and he was he was
really upset that the whiteboard
happened to be in his mind a few inches
positioned too low and it became such a
systemic failure of how this decision
was made in the organization that he
started asking around and just driving
up and seeing how this decision was made
and and the understanding was actually
eventually through this process a group
of folks were actually let go from the
organization and it we debated this me
and my friend for a bit to say like what
is this a good thing to like be focused
on something ultimately and maybe both
our minds was quite trivial and like and
also why right like Ray Dalio is he's 70
years old he's many times over like a
billionaire like just just chill out and
go relax and enjoy the rest of your life
why be so fixated on this just this
meaningless point and beyond that to my
friend was telling me how he would read
every single like new associates papers
in the company and if it was not up to
par he would chew that person out in
front of the whole company in an
organization and so we debated this for
a little while and where we landed on
that I think at least this this concept
connected with me for why why this
matters at all to Ray still given where
he is in life is that in his mind like
Bridgewater associates is is his like
Picasso and if you're pedantic you're
saying well Picasso is the person and
it's actually the art piece and so good
for you but where we landed on was that
the reason why ray cares so much is this
is his life's work and he's going to be
fixated on every single point that
matters for him in
obsessive manner until until he's done
and so that that resonated with me and
it's it's something that I think the the
way that was articulated by my friend
and explaining why he's so fixing and
all these details even to the level
where it oftentimes may be considered
micromanagement which is actually a bad
form of Management but like how are we
all going to be searching for like our
own sense of what we want to pursue
maybe for the rest of our lives right if
we could if we're gonna go do something
and found a company and I thought about
this more and I guess I'm going to
conclude with just a few stories for me
personally it's about you know if Ray
can be so obsessed about a hedge fund
like certainly anyone out there can find
something based on like a cause that you
care about or or a betterment of
humanity that you could really be
passionate about and for me it's always
like the stories that are impacting
people that I find most moving and so
yeah I went through and like these are
some of the things that have happened
with with creators on on patreon that I
personally followed and so this is a
group called kind of funny they actually
were a group that spun out of I'm a
gamer and so I read this site called IGN
so that's where they were originally but
they all quit and decide to just
continue talking about you know stories
and games as a group together just out
of their home and so initially like they
were putting their stuff on YouTube and
they were getting maybe 15,000 to
100,000 views per video which you know
people have an impression of nowadays
when when you find YouTube influencers
that that's not a big number but they
ended up launching a patreon page to ask
for sort of support on their endeavor
and then very quickly they were
generating 30,000 a month on on the
videos they're making and they were like
well this is cool but we also really
care about gaming and so they set up a
second page that soon exceeded the 30
and they were making their and they
effectively then had two pages and they
were making tens of thousands of dollars
a month and so that allowed them to move
out of that sort of home studio set up a
proper studio get upgrade their
equipment have an actual back job in
professional setting hire other folks to
help them on their on the content that
they're making and then ultimately
really just grow out their business and
I thought that was so cool watching this
group jump out because they care deeply
about the work they were doing from IGN
where I followed them originally and be
able to rebuild back up their company so
I thought that was awesome okay another
group that actually it's a single
individual a guy named Brian Stann have
you ever seen some of these images are
humans of New York and I love what
Brandon sort of does because he just
takes images of people originally in New
York and then sort of just like writes
out their story right like one one
snippet of it and I think it builds a
lot of empathy and you just get to
develop a lot of perspective about other
people's lives this and I think it
touches on a lot of things that are
highly relevant in problems that people
are dealing with innovation this one
resonated with me in particular
it's about anxiety and so this
individual talks about how he almost
like bullied this girl in high school
who always talked about anxiety because
it looked like nothing to him but then
you know recently when when his father
died he's been dealing with his personal
anxiety and realized that it wasn't
anxiety to him was not about nothing
it's the indescribable fear of nothing
is the way to talks about it and humans
in New York just does all these
different stories that I think in pieces
sort of helps like shine a light into
different parts of humanity and brings
us closer together when they finally
launched their patreon page there was
just an outpouring of support and people
talking about how sharing you know their
personal stories brought so much
encouragement to them and then also how
you know actual causes like a woman
being able to send her children to
school
we're sort of achieved through the
stories that were shared by Bren so I
thought that was awesome and then
finally one of I find Simone Gertz is
another youtuber she makes this channel
called shitty robots do a quick like 30
seconds here did you see what I do
because it's a little bit it's gnarly
but I'm an inventor and youtuber my
goodies aren't shitty right but
hopefully they're fun I mean it's like
it's some sort of robot comedy sometimes
I just take a step out it outside of
everything in a Mike this is really
bizarre that I built the useless
machines and have somehow turning this
into a job and into a career but I do
like thinking like when I pay for a
coffee I'm like shitty robots paid for
that so Simona's is awesome right she
did I recently did like the thing where
she converted Tesla into a truck before
the actual Tesla truck
she's been on Colbert done a TED talk
work with Mythbusters Adam Savage on
many things and last year she had a
recurrence of a brain tumor and so in
particular she shared a video at that
time when it came back where she
described despite all the uncertainties
in the difficulty she was facing in sort
of her own life and going through this
the the to stable certainties in her
life were both her community of patrons
and her mother and as she sort of shared
this particular example and this video a
lot of folks just sort of had like an
outpouring of support and just sort of
seeing this I think both empathy from
people and like a community sort of
focusing their their love and energy to
individuals and the internet sort of
enabling this to happen with communities
today I think despite
like whatever other hardships and
struggles that you know patreon goes
through and will continue to go through
it's very motivating for both the team
and myself to keep focusing on this and
so again my my call for everyone who
cares about doing startups and finding
what it is that they are passionate
about is to find your Picasso or again
if you're pedantic you're yeah you're at
your actual art piece that's it two
questions okay how does that work and
then I'll repeat the question
okay oh yeah sure yeah
I think we've had a lot of discussions
about the exit per se too because what's
been important for us is that in order
to serve creators we want to be able to
remain independent and our
decision-making and so we've been really
strategic both in the partners and
investors that we brought on for how we
raise our money and also into whether we
would sell the company to to will sell
patreon to another company in particular
we look at like the actions of some of
these largest companies and we feel like
it's it's difficult to trust that in the
future they wouldn't change the
trajectory or how we operate so the plan
for us has always been to try to figure
out a path to IPO yeah and though the
way that we get there has been working
deeply with investors are looking at
comparable metrics and just figuring out
what we need to do in order to make it
there yeah
one more yeah like you're the last piece
of advice was kind of like to find your
Picasso in general like do life you know
there are always so many different
fields you're exploring you might be
learning you know for example you were
like playing piano as a child before you
went into computer science I guess I'm
just interested in hearing your insight
on like in terms of like navigating so
many different fields I'm just really
keeping your mind open and working as
much as possible how do you go about
finding that one that ends up being that
like passionate really you know over
time especially if you're like starting
at a younger age ya know right how can I
repeat that question basically what I
heard was there are a lot of different
paths that you can take and things that
you can be passionate about and how do
you sort of figure out the the path and
maybe the focus that you want to take as
you go through life and so I think one
important distinction here I want to
call out is that I'm not being
prescriptive in order to just like
describe how to be successful I actually
think there's a lot of luck involved at
least your personal experience on like
what actually will work out and it's
also hard to predict what I am trying to
describe is like what will make it worth
it for you to work on the problems and
and that's what I mean by like finding
something you deeply care about there
have been a lot of endeavors that I've
worked on that have gone nowhere and you
look at some of these other founders too
and where they started it looks very
different from where they finished and
so the thing that will kill you for
certain is if you just end up hitting a
wall and you you don't want to do it
anymore
which is also fine I think as a choice
but like ultimately if you're going to
be exerting this much effort on
something that has a high likelihood of
not working out I think the only way you
get through it
is if you have deep conviction and
you're passionate about it and so then
directly to your question like as you're
exploring lots of different branches and
and whatnot what I found is it doesn't
really matter like where your journey
takes you I've always found
it interesting to obsess down like
deeply into one path at a time and then
something else takes me to to broaden
out my experience or my knowledge then
then I'll follow it but I always find it
more interesting to just learn as much
as I can about a particular field as I'm
working on it that's good okay all right
thanks everyone
[Applause]